una pelota sale disparada hacia el aire
desde el techo de un edificio que tiene
50 metros de altura desde el piso si su
velocidad inicial es de 20 metros por
segundo y además la ecuación h h de
altura es igual a menos 16 t cuadrado
más 2050 modela la altura de la pelota
después de t segundos en cuánto tiempo
chocar a la pelota en el suelo y bueno
en varias listas de física que hacemos
en khan academy podemos ver por qué esta
ecuación modela o describe el
comportamiento de la pelota al salir del
techo sería muy bueno que tú revisadas
estas listas algún día sin embargo en
esta ocasión no voy a dar por hecho
nosotros sabemos que esta es la ecuación
que modela la altura de la pelota dado
algún tiempo y bueno si te das cuenta
que la pelota choque con el suelo quiere
decir que la altura se haga cero y si
tenemos una ecuación de la altura lo que
tenemos que hacer es resolver esta
ecuación porque la altura vale cero
me queda que 0 es igual a menos 16 de
cuadrada más 2050 y lo que estoy
buscando precisamente es las 3 que
cumplan esto ahora date cuenta que todo
es divisible entre dos y de hecho autos
digestible entre menos dos entonces lo
que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre
menos dos para que te cuadrada me quede
positivo menos 16 entre menos dos me da
88 de cuadrada y después 20 entre menos
2 me da menos 10 cm y después más 50
entre menos 2 me da menos 25 y ya tengo
una ecuación cuadrática igual a cero
está en su posición estándar o si
quieres lo podemos ver así tachamos esto
e igualamos aquí a cero y estamos en su
posición estándar por lo tanto podemos
completar el vídeo al cuadrado perfecto
o hacer lo que se nos ocurra pero
también podemos aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática y en esta ocasión vamos a
aplicar la fórmula cuadrática y para
esto necesitamos saber cuál es el valor
de a que por cierto es el que está al
lado de la de cuadrada cuál es el valor
de b que por cierto es el que está al
lado de la t y cuál es el valor de s
aquí tenemos que avale 8 b vale menos 10
y c vale menos 25 y que por cierto la
fórmula cuadrática me dice que
soluciones en este caso que son t son de
la forma más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada menos 4 hacen entre 2 am por lo
tanto lo único que hay que hacer es
sustituir los valores de ápice en esta
ecuación que es igual a menos b pero
menos por menos me va a dar más
entonces me queda 10 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada es decir de menos
10 al cuadrado lo cual me da 100 menos 4
por que es 8 x sé que es menos 25 menos
4 por 8 x menos 25
todo esto dividido entre dos veces a 2
por 8 es lo mismo que 16 y bueno pues
vamos a simplificar lo más que se pueda
toda esta ecuación menos cuatro menos
por menos me da más entonces esto se va
y me queda cuatro por ocho 32 32 por 5
bueno es lo mismo que 4 por 25 que 100
por 8 800 entonces me va a quedar que
esto es lo mismo que 10 más menos la
raíz cuadrada de 900 entre 16 y 900
tiene raíz cuadrada exacta esos 30
entonces me queda días más
y 30 que es la raíz cuadrada de 900
entre 16 y bueno entonces que ya tengo
mis dos soluciones la primera es con
signo más 10 más 30 que es 40 entre 16 y
aquí puedo simplificar por sacar cuarta
tanto arriba como abajo me queda 10
entre 4 de chopo simplificar más puedo
sacar octava y me queda 5 entre 25
medios y ahora me voy a fijar con el
signo menos y me queda que te es igual a
10 menos 30 lo cual me da menos 20 20
entre 16 y aquí voy a sacar mitad de
hechos y voy a sacar quartet me queda
menos 5 sobre 4 y bueno ya tenemos dos
soluciones para ti pero no hay que
perder de vista la idea de que este es
el tiempo y estamos hablando de un
problema físico entonces no podemos
tener tiempos negativos
no podemos tener que te valga menos
cinco cuartos eso no tiene sentido por
lo tanto el valor que en verdad
soluciona este problema físico este
igual a cinco medios que es lo mismo que
2.5 que por cierto no olvidemos las
unidades son cinco medios segundos o 2.5
segundos lo que me da de respuesta
este problema físico que ahorita no me
voy a meter en problemas físicos de
pensar porque esta es la solución en la
cual la pelota choca con el suelo lo que
se puede hacer es verificar que en
efecto esta sea la solución que mete
esto igual a cero por lo tanto vamos a
comprobar y para esto me voy a agarrar
la ecuación original y voy a sustituir
el valor de t por cinco medios y me
queda menos 16 que multiplica a t
cuadrada es decir a cinco medios
elevados al cuadrado más 20 por t es
decir más 20 por 5 medios más 50 y esto
tiene que ser igual a 0 y vamos a ver
menos 16 5 al cuadrado me da 25 ya esto
lo tengo que dividir entre 42 por dos es
cuatro y aquí me queda 20 entre 2 me da
10 10 por 5 me da 50 entonces es más 50
más 50 y eso tiene que ser igual a cero
y ahora a continuación voy a decir menos
16 entre 4 me da menos 4 menos 4 x 25 es
lo mismo que menos 100 si es negativo
más 50 agua exprés
menos 100 menos 150 50 igual a 0 no
olvidemos los signos y dice 100 negativo
más 50 más 50 pues esto claramente 0 0
es igual a 0 y por lo tanto ya tenemos
la comprobación cuando nosotros tenemos
el tiempo igual a 5 medios oa 2.5
segundos se cumple que la pelota choca
con el suelo y además este tiempo cumple
que tiene un sentido completamente
lógico y físico